das in jedem fall und wir schauen in die
ukraine seit kriegsbeginn war er nicht
mehr hier hier in der ukraine präsident
zwar gestern in geheimer mission in der
zurückeroberten stadt ja und die bilder
die sie hier sehen würden erst ganz spät
am abend freigegeben zu groß ist die
angst vor einem anschlag die spuren der
zerstörung sind hier überall sichtbar
hier trifft er sich dann mit seinen
militärs lässt sich die lage die lage
erklären und besichtigt die orte der
zerstörung hat halt auch orden für die
tapferen soldaten die für ihre heimat
hier kämpfen und diese stadtrat schiff
zurückerobert
ja in hf konnten die russen erfolgreich
zurückgedrängt werden doch ein stück
weiter südlich wird heftig gekämpft in
don was sind raketeneinschläge im
minuten takt zu hören unser bild
reporter björn stritzel ist für uns
weiterhin dort wo die kämpfe nicht
aufhören wollen und genau da sieht es
gar nicht so gut aus für die
ein neues mario pohl ein neuer kessel
droht hier mitten im donbass mitten im
osten der ukraine bei den zwillings
stettens wir denn jetzt und lucio hier
wollen die russen einen neuen
belagerungsring ziehen der plan beide
steht in einer zangenbewegung einkesseln
die ukrainische verteidiger von der
versorgung abschneidet und vernichten
die folgen noch mehr leid und noch mehr
tote
denn auch einige zivilisten leben immer
noch hier musikern selbst ist beinahe
menschenleer nur wenige der früheren
100.000 einwohner sind geblieben viele
flohen nicht nur wegen des ständigen
bombardements sondern auch aus angst vor
den russischen soldaten
adam ist geblieben leutnant einer
spezialeinheit der ukrainischen polizei
er patrouilliert mit einem kollegen auf
den straßen von lucio
ich habe familie ehefrauen kind sie sind
in sicherheit auch von der ukraine
kontrolliertem gebiet
die städte und dörfer
gekennzeichnet vom krieg kaum ein haus
ohne spuren vom beschuss oder
explosionen wir sind hier in musik einer
stadt in der ost ukraine belagert wird
von der russischen armee zusammen mit
ihrer partnerstadt sie wieder im netz
die sind wir hinter mir diese beiden
städte werden beständig beschossen von
russischer raketen artillerie
die gefahr ist nicht nur die der
ständigen beschuss für die einwohner
sondern eine noch viel größere gefahr
besteht in der einkesselung die
russischen streitkräfte haben beide
städte von drei seiten bereits umzingelt
und es tut sich ein szenario wie in
mario pohl zu wiederholen dass also
tausende zivilisten und die verbliebenen
ukrainischen verwendete abgeschnitten
werden von in versorgungslinien eine
kleine straße die lebensader der fast
umzingelten region diese konnten die
russen noch nicht einnehmen nur hier
gelang wieder rein und fliehende raus
doch die nachschubroute liegt unter
ständigen beschuss deutlich zeigt sich
hier die ukrainische verteidiger
brauchen dringend schwere waffen denn
die russische armee verfügt über weitaus
mehr artillerie und raketenwerfer kann
viel öfter auf die ukrainische stellung
feuern als umgekehrt dabei kommen auch
immer öfters putins höllen waffen zum
einsatz hier sehen wir wie ein wohnort
in der region lohans von russischen
thermo bayerischen bomben völlig
zerstört wird die explosion lässt
sauerstoff brennen und erzeugt ein
tödliches vakuum in der umgebung doch
trotz des grausamen vormarsches der
russen will ukraine präsident wolodimir
selensky die donbass region und nicht
aufgeben
wenn die besitzer denken dass lehmann
und sie wurden gehören werde hören sie
sich der donbass wird ukrainisch sein
weil er uns war er unser kern ist selbst
wenn russland dort zerstörung und leid
anrichten werden wir jede stadt und jede
gemeinde wieder aufbauen es gibt keine
echte alternative zur griechischen
flagge das wird sich auch nicht geben
werden die zwillings steht die wiro
donezk und musikern bald zu einem neuen
mario pohl werden noch ist der kessel
nicht geschlossen noch gibt es hoffnung
für die verbliebenen ukraine
[Musik]
jan unser kollege bier und schnitzel ist
auch heute wieder im umkämpften gebiet
des donners unterwegs und genau zu ihm
halten wir jetzt guten morgen gehören ja
die frage die wir gerade auch im beitrag
gestellt haben könnten diese städte zu
einem zweiten mario pohl werden
also die gefahr besteht insofern
tatsächlich das seit einigen wochen die
russischen streitkräfte sich in einer
zangenbewegung eine zangenbewegung um
diesen um diesen kessel gelegt haben um
diese beiden zwillings städte sich sich
von norden von süden und von osten
genähert haben immer weiter die
verteidigung bestellungen mit artillerie
beschießen und mittlerweile auch die
letzte zufahrtstraße immer wieder
beschließen können also immer wieder
unter feuer legen können was es sehr
schwer macht personen und zu evaluieren
und auch hilfsgüter wieder hinein zu
bringen die stadt für die verteidiger
insofern ist das schon eine sehr prekäre
lage allerdings sieht es bis jetzt noch
nicht so aus als als können dieser
kessel wirklich tatsächlich geschlossen
werden wir haben da auch mit einigen mit
einigen leuten gesprochen die weiter
dort bleiben wollen sowohl zivilisten
als auch als auch
mitglieder der der sicherheitskräfte und
ja die wollen dort alle ausharren und
ungeachtet dieser session offensive
warum ist die verteidigung des osten ist
eigentlich so viel schwieriger als zum
beispiel zu beginn des krieges die
verteidigung der hauptstadt kiew
also das hat ja zum einen so ein wenig
strukturelle gründe dass das natürlich
eine region ist die die zum einen ja
schon länger sich also seid 2014 sich
schon im krieg befindet wo es auf beiden
seiten sozusagen schon fest artillerie
stellungen gibt und wo man sozusagen
auch die den den feind auf der anderen
seite schon schon ganz gut kennt und zum
anderen ist natürlich so dass die
hauptstadt kiew
sah sich zwar auch einer umzingelung
irgendwann mal ausgesetzt perspektivisch
aber da hatte die russischen hatte eine
russische streitkräfte im prinzip nie
genügend soldaten nie genügen verbände
herangeführt um ernsthaft einen kessel
darum zu legen um ernsthaft eine
zangenbewegung um mithilfe abzuschneiden
geschweige denn die stadt zu stürmen das
ist hier am donnerstag wenig anders
diese taktik auf die straße streitkräfte
umgeschwenkt haben also auch nicht mehr
in einer großen zangen bewegung größere
städte wie kartons und und andere
einschließen sondern in kleineren
kesseln versuchen einzelne städte
abzuschneiden also mit solchen mit
solchen kleinen kesseln immer wieder
einen planung screen zu legen und dann
die verbliebenen verteidiger dort eben
zu beschließen bis sie aufgeben oder
vernichtet werden gern wir haben eben
bilder gesehen von präsident see lenski
der hf besucht hat so lange zeit war
nicht dort jetzt ist ja wieder dorthin
gereist was bedeutet sein besuch für die
menschen vor ort und auch für die
kämpfenden soldaten
also ich habe mit leuten gesprochen die
man schon waren schon sehr angetan von
dem besuch also sowohl zivilisten als
auch soldaten die mir den ich
geschrieben habe sei nehme stark an dass
das hat auch wenn das natürlich nur eine
gotische evidenz ist aber dass das auch
auf viele auf viele leute und einen
moralischen moralischen schub gibt wenn
der präsident jetzt erstmals den osten
des landes und die zweitgrößte stadt ja
auch wochenlang unter schwerem beschuss
lag wenn er die besucht hat ja auch
allerdings auch bei dem besuch gleich
noch gleich noch einmal deutlich gemacht
das dass
diejenigen die sich eine verteidigung
der stadt beteiligt haben die sozusagen
die stadt gegen die russin version
verteidigt haben dass er die als helden
ausgelobt hat und auch
orden verliehen den geheimdienstchef
wiederum der den spd chef der stadt den
hat er gefeuert gestern das kam ein
wenig überraschend dort aber anscheinend
laufen das schon länger ermittlungen
gegen ihnen dass es
ihm wird vorgeworfen da nicht genügend
für die verteidigung der stadt getan zu
haben bzw ja also dass ich tatsächlich
das wort kollaboration und dergleichen
vier nicht aber es war schon ein
deutlicher vorwurf er habe sich nicht
genug in der verteidigung der stadt
beteiligt also selensky zieht dann auch
konsequenzen besten dank für die
einschätzung von vor ort live aus dem
dorf